In this section of our course, we are going to take a look at the optimized metahumans.
We have the option of downloading from Quixel Bridge.
And look at how they differ from the cinematic quality metahumans that we have been looking
at up until now.
Optimized metahumans are available to download for Unreal Engine versions 5.4 and later.
They allow for better performance while offering comparable levels of fidelity to the cinematic
ones.
You can choose between high, medium, and low optimized.
The average file size is under 100 megabytes as opposed to the cinematic ones that range
between 2 to 3 gigabytes.
They come with compressed textures and optimized materials as opposed to the full resolution
textures with separate materials.
The harems are also optimized and the LODs have been adjusted with animation settings
that enable and disable correctives based on LOD.
Now let's jump into Unreal Engine and take a look at these differences.
Throughout this course, we have been using the cinematic quality version of this metahuman.
In the metahumans folder, we also have a low optimized version of this character.
I have opened up the blueprints for both the cinematic and low optimized versions of this
character.
Going back to the cinematic quality version, let's compare some of the components.
With the body components selected, let's open up the skeletal mesh for this metahuman.
We will see all of the joints and correctives are present.
Now if we go to the low quality version and open up the skeletal mesh, we will notice
that this has a simplified version of the skeleton.
If we toggle between the two skeletons, we will notice that the cinematic quality skeleton
has the correctives and the low optimized one does not.
Now let's compare the face components of these two.
If we select the face component on the cinematic quality version and then open up the skeletal
mesh, we will see all of the joints and correctives are present.
Now if we go to the low optimized version, select the face component and then open up
the skeletal mesh, we will notice we have a more simplified skeleton.
We can compare the two if we toggle between them.
Going back to the cinematic quality blueprint, we will also see all of the material instances
this has for the face.
If we compare this with the low optimized version, we can see this only has four simplified
material instances.
Now going back to the cinematic version, if we select the metahuman component, we will
see that we have physics for the clothing and can choose if we want to disable correctives.
If we compare this with the low optimized version by selecting the metahuman component,
we will see that there is no physics for the clothing and the correctives are disabled
by default.
Now going back to the cinematic version, if we select the lod sync component, we have
eight lod's.
If we compare this with the low optimized version by selecting the lod sync component,
we will see that this has only two lod's.
Now before we move on, let's do a quick review of what we just covered.
When comparing the face and body skeletons of the optimized and cinematic metahumans,
the optimized ones will have reduced bone count and may not have any correctives for
the neck and body.
Optimized metahumans have been specifically tailored with performance in mind, especially
when working in games, mobile or with real time experiences.
Now let's begin to wrap up this course with some final recommendations.